خرج مدير الفرع الفرنسي لشركه تويتر
داميان فيل معلنا استقالته من منصبه هذه
الاستقاله كانت اشاره واضحه على ان
المشكلات التي تواجه تويتر تعدت حدود سان
فرانسيسكو ووصلت الى باريس
فييال اعلى استقالته من تويتر على تويتر
لكن ماذا تعني هذه الاستقاله بالنسبه
لمؤثرين فرنسيين على تويتر ثم احدها هؤلاء
تحدث الان عن حاله من الضياع وعدم اليقين
حول تاثير ما يواجهه تويتر على المستخدمين
الفرنسيين كومبو
كل المستخدم
من غير الواضح الى انها ستذهب الامور هل
سيكون هناك توازن اكثر ام اقل ما نراه حتى
الان انا الاموره
هذا مشكلات كثيره
هذه المشكلات تتعلق بالدرجه الاولى بمساء
الى قانونيه اذن التباينات بين القوانين
الفرنسيه والامريكيه كبيره جدا
في لحظه ماء سوف يصطدم ذلك بالقوانين
الفرنسيه وسندخل في الواقع تويتر هو عالم
الافتراضي لكن لديه تاثيرات قويه على
الواقع ويقدر عدد المستخدمين الفرنسيين
النشيطين على تويتر شهريا ب 16 مليون
مستخدم حتى الان لم تؤثر المشكلات التي
تعصف بالعصفور الازرق على استخدامهم
للموقع فادي دهوك العربيه باريس